I really don't know how I want to play
as I mentioned ya blazed it's funny
because Neal Brennan - and you know Neal
Brennan I've met Neal Brennan right so
he I said that I am mentioned that you
were gonna be on my podcast because I
know him too like he got all cocky about
it I went to the comedy store with him
once I think oh you did yeah I met him
and then we went to the comedy store on
like a double date and then that was it
that was the extent of and you never saw
me after yeah yeah I'm not great with
with keeping in touch with people either
you know that albino right yeah yeah I
also DMD you about the the ping pong did
I really I did yeah when I first
discovered the podcast ID MDX and did I
respond to the do I wanna [ __ ] like
throw me some names if I would de I'm
back just give me some names out there
uh Bryce Halleck no give me some big
names okay uh George Clooney no way no
way Chris Hemsworth now I don't even
know that who that is right but this guy
I would DM to write back
Paul banks yes him well I appreciate
that he's being really cocky about how
he beats you but the man needed a blood
transfusion as described but also when
you said you looking in the eyes and you
saw it you know that the defeat watch
over me
I feel like you did kind of then bounce
I feel like we didn't actually have like
a long chat all right social it's a it's
a it's a self-preservation thing he
thinks the longer he stays in social
situations the worse it's gonna get for
him and he will be forced to reveal his
true neurotic nature yes I mean I
identify with that you do you really
yeah yeah yeah I'm like nervous now I'm
nervous no - yeah here's the thing it's
what it is is that I always say
something that I regret in social
situations right so um your fatty story
is one of my favorite stories we have
seen
yeah well I poked him with this the aaaa
see you know that's so yes so that's why
you know I don't like talk to people in
length especially like him I will
because I don't give a [ __ ] what he
thinks right mm-hmm
but when it's some but I mean I love you
I really do if you die I do it'll be
devastating
would that feel good yeah right if you
know I don't yeah it would be
devastating yeah it would be it would
have been about [ __ ] mad it would
have been yeah
back before my brother cut off but yeah
well you were with but SOPA dude you
don't want to be using gonna change this
I'm taking this off it's warm right or
he's flexing right now sexual what I
just and we're back yeah we don't cut
that out either though yeah look I love
that whole thing slow-mo yeah yeah it
was cute now listen are you so when
people text you you don't text back
right away no I'm actually really good
I'm good with that kind of communication
I'm just not great in social situations
ah yeah even in groups especially I mean
I think a little similar to you yeah
yeah probably for the same reasons that
you were just saying but yeah I mean I
don't know it's just sort of social
anxiety why we're caught we're nervous
wrecks yeah and I have like if you look
at my hands now oh yes I always appear
like baseline cool but I actually I'm
constantly dying on the inside really so
that's why him and I bond because of
that because when he wants to bounce I'm
okay bouncing too I'm not trying to
stick around because I feel that same
type of yeah I had to audition later
day and I was in the lobby and the the
assistants of this casting River came
out and he go oh finally you show up
fine you know for once which is I want
to tell them the reason I don't show up
because I don't I'm gonna eat it in
there right like I just what I want to
say but I go I give them hugs and I walk
in and I just shut down I told him
remember I was gonna kill me audition
part you shut down oh yeah they go are
you ready and I just don't know what the
[ __ ]
mm-hmm you know like if I'm on a set I
know have the job I
I know how to do it right sometimes man
in those rooms it's the same feeling as
I have at parties where it's just like I
just shut the [ __ ] down you know any but
how do you I mean you've obviously done
it successfully a bunch of times to get
the work that you have know what it is
is that it's one out of every three
times maybe mm-hmm I'll like there's a
couple where I went I would walk out and
go holy [ __ ] that was actually pretty
good right but that's rare usually it's
I think you perform better when he's a
little underslept
and he doesn't his mind hasn't caught up
to what's actually happening again so
the the later on in the day that he
auditions the more he's thought about it
and that's when he [ __ ] himself over
when you when when you don't have enough
rest you're sort of in survival mode
you're kind of just trying to get get
through it yeah you're not thinking
about the tiny little details of it yeah
because at the end of the day it's
because and this is gonna sound really
weird every time I think I'm gonna be
I'm the best kind for this regardless of
who's going against me in my head I'm
like yeah but you have to show that
Bobby and sometimes I don't show it and
I [ __ ] and destroy myself you piece
of [ __ ] if you kill your soul she's real
after all that [ __ ] [ __ ] I treat
myself so poorly you know so it's like
so I do it there but I do it also and at
parties this [ __ ] see you have social
do you have performance anxiety not not
with you know rock music and being on
stage doing songs but pretty much in any
any other context
I mean I always like I settle in but I
tried some acting and that was that was
a really interesting interesting
experience because I was so nervous for
the read all read when you're in the
room with the actors yeah and it's the
worst if you're trying to have you if
you're feeling anxious everything is the
worst especially like just all those
people and everyone's so natural reading
the lines and you know I really found
that very uncomfortable yeah then we
shot and it was like we did 14 takes and
fortunately for me like 13 takes there
was like a camera problem or you know at
least that's what they told me or you
know it was a really long shot where we
had to go through a hallway and the
cameraman had to follow the actors and
so there was a lot of moving pieces to
the scene why so I got to do all these
you know I got to do 14 takes and by the
14th one I finally relaxed yeah to the
scene and then I felt like oh that's
that's what acting is and that's really
fun to just sort of be in that moment
and free and you're not thinking about
what you're supposed to say what they're
supposed to say just kind of like doing
I don't know what it is but it felt good
yeah but that's what and that might be
the payoff you're talking about when you
actually have when you do it that's the
payoff but when you're auditioning
that's not what that is yeah it's a
competition to me yeah yeah instead of
showing instead of being my mentality
being
show them what you would do with it
right I don't think that way I think you
have to win you know when you have the
job I know that like I learned from like
guys like Jamie Kennedy's I think he's a
ok actor I remember I did a movie with
Jamie Kennedy where he said one line
forty times in a row and I go what is
that you guys I'm doing a run so they'll
just take whatever that's sounding one
is yeah wait on camera acting it out
he'd just repeated the same line over
and over yeah it's like his coverage
right and he has maybe one or two lines
he'll do do those two lines over and
over and then the in editing they just
picked the best one right but in an
audition you try one time go ahead okay
thank you and you're like
how long is the scene usually when you
do that oh man
some of them are like pages long a fact
for strange what's a straight stranger
things because that was I didn't know it
was stranger things it was different it
was a different title yeah and I didn't
think I was gonna get it and it was so
long that I'm like I'm not gonna get
this so that was and then they were like
we like him
I think I'd tape for that oh really I
think I did I mean I don't know if the
same part but I taped for an episode of
that was it for a school teacher no
Asians no I think when when she's like
on the lam with that group of misfits
you know like in a factory somewhere I
think it was one of those dudes Wow
did you tape it on your own you have to
go to until I was on tour a hotel room I
think RZA didn't help me with that one
RZA helped me with another one yeah yeah
Monsoor I know he's a good actor yeah I
know the RZA is a good actor but I also
read somewhere were you that's something
that you've done like you know younger
when you were younger a buddy of mine
wrote a script that was really cool and
then he wanted me to be in that film and
he had no budget so we were gonna do a
teaser trailer where the idea yet can I
get a tiny bit more juice on this I feel
quiet bobby's for a ghost give me the
juice man he's got the juice
all right so we shot a couple scenes
that were then spliced together to make
a trailer and that was then supposed to
be used to get funding for the for the
feature but that never happened I did
the trailer yeah yeah that was I mean I
think the only like dialogue was a
voiceover I was like on the phone and
there was no interacting with another
person yeah which I don't know if that
is harder would that be harder to you to
just like recite a monologue into a
phone if you have nobody I would imagine
that would be pretty hard I think that
would be like my only experience with it
yeah yeah that would it wasn't easy and
then yeah I asked a really great actor
actually for advice on that um Brady
Corbett oh yeah a big director yeah and
his like advice was like to do nothing
you know I kind of read it through like
just read it off the page to him he's
like hey just do that yeah just like
just do nothing which is easier said
than done the eats
[Music]